or so many of you out there feel that
the Oscars are not worth one minute of
your time don't worry I got you covered
I'll give you the winners in less than
that the winners are cinematography Hugo
art direction Hugo costume designed the
artist makeup the Iron Lady foreign film
is separation supporting actress Octavia
Spencer editing Girl with the Dragon
Tattoo sound editing Hugo sound mixing
Hugo documentary undefeated Animated
Feature Rango best visual effects Hugo
again over Apes really supporting actor
Christopher Plummer original score of
the artists original song man or Muppet
from the Muppets say that 10 times fast
adapted screenplay The Descendants
original screenplay midnight in Paris
live-action short the shore documentary
short saving face out animated short the
Fantastic Flying books of mr. Morris
Lessmore directing Michel Hazanavicius
the artists best actor Jean Dujardin the
artist best actress Meryl Streep the
Iron Lady there we go 17 nominations now
three wins that's an absurd amount and
Best Picture the artist time and there
you go folks those are the winners of
the 84th Annual Academy Awards thank you
to all who were hanging out on my
Twitter during the Academy Awards that's
where the party was you know cuz you
were there and yeah I know the video is
over a minute long but I said the
winners in less than a minute that's
what I meant so what did you think of
the Oscars this year whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more